foreign  [Music]  how good a woman your mama was  she took Colton Briggs the coldest  killer that I've ever met and she turned  him into a family man  I'm almost dead now  [Applause]  coming in one way or another  foreign  there's  no room for vengeance  [Music]  you're protecting a killer  from another killer  can you teach me how to shoot  yeah well then you put your hands behind  your back a break especially at Rossi  my father wants you done I'll blow her  brains all over this Valley  you're getting scared of nothing  Briggs decides he's coming oh grades is  coming he's here sound like he's the one  who's scared  my whole life I'd seen fear in the eyes  of every man I ever happened  let's do this the old way is my father  still a good man  you boy [ __ ] up the devil  foreign  [Music]  [Music]